Is marijuana smoke “healthier” than tobacco
smoke?
Hi everyone, Crystal Dilworth your friendly
nicotine researcher here for DNews.
So everybody knows that smoking tobacco causes
cancer, and second hand smoke is really bad
for you too.
The mixture of gases and particles that make
up tobacco smoke contains more than 7,000
different chemical compounds.
It’s estimated that over 250 of these chemicals
are harmful, and at least 70 of them cause
cancer.
But cancer isn’t the only negative effect
of smoking.
Exposure to tobacco smoke immediately affects
the heart, blood vessels, and blood circulation.
Many smokers die of heart disease, not cancer.
For instance, in California a Tobacco Control
Program has been associated with preventing
59,000 deaths resulting from heart disease
between 1989 and 1997.
This is partially because our bodies respond
to secondhand smoke the same way it responds
to mechanical injury, by increasing our blood
platelets.
When these specialized blood cells clump together,
they stop us from bleeding.
But when platelets are activated in the absence
of a gushing wound, they can aggregate in
unhealthy ways that cause strokes and heart
disease.
But for those of you who think smoke from
those “other kinds of cigarettes” is probably
healthier (after all, it’s totally organic).
Think Again!
At least when it comes to heart disease, smoke
is smoke whether it also contains nicotine
or THC.
Nicotine, the addictive component of tobacco,
and tetrahydrocannabinol (THC), the psychoactive
component of Marijuana, are present in second
hand smoke.
So even if you don’t want to be, you are
exposing yourself to these compounds by just
being around people smoking either substance.
However, a new study suggests that it’s
the other compounds in the smoke that have
a negative effect, at least, on your cardiovascular
health.
Researchers used a cigarette-smoking machine
to expose rats to either tobacco or marijuana
smoke and measured the function of their main
leg artery using ultrasound.
Blood vessel dilation was recorded before
smoke exposure and at 10 minute and 40 minute
time points post-exposure and it was observed
that blood vessel function dropped 70 percent
after 30 minutes of exposure to either smoke.
When scientists repeated the study, this time
with tobacco that didn’t contain nicotine,
or marijuana that didn’t contain THC, the
same drop in function was observed.
So its not the “buzz” or the “high”
that’ll give you a heart attack, it’s
the smoke itself.
Aside: Don’t worry, they used a negative
control, rats exposed to plain old air didn’t
show reduced blood vessel function at all.
whew!
These results lead me to suspect that any
type of smoke could cause vasoconstriction
and reduced blood vessel function.
So stay away from house fires.
And when camping, consider that if the sugar
from all those marshmallows you’re roasting
doesn’t give you diabetes, the smoke from
the campfire is probably increasing your risk
for heart disease.
So stay in school kids, don’t smoke, don’t
do drugs, and just say “no” to camping.
What do you think? is marijuana smoke just
as bad as tobacco smoke?
Subscribe to D News and let us know in the
comments down below!
You can also come find me on twitter at PolyCrystalHD